Dr. Alexei, more commonly known as just Alexei,
was likely born in the late 1940s, and raised
in Soviet Russia, where he went on to become
a scientist, where he would develop a machine
designed to open a gate into the alternate
realm known as the Upside Down.
This is the same thing that Dr. Martin Brenner
was trying to utilize Eleven and MK-Ultra
for two years earlier.
However, when Alexei is abducted by Jim Hopper
and Joyce Byers, he proves to be more than
just a Russian scientist.
Alexei is an individual with his own dreams
and ambitions to become... a consumer of slurpees
and Burger King?
“Two Whoppers, extra ketchup, large fry, and one
extra large, slurpee.”
Alexei is actually not alone in his excitement
over commodities from the United States,
they play a direct role in what leads to his
eventual death.
And no, I don’t mean from the sugars, fats
and cholesterol of the food Alexei likes to
eat.
To learn more about Alexei and why his love
of cherry slurpees is actually very important,
stick around to the end of this video.
Welcome to Horror History -- in this lesson
I’ll be covering the life and meaning of
this Looney Tune loving commie from the third
season of Stranger Things.
The funny thing is, Alexei’s story kind
of comes true in a way for the actor that
played him, Alec Utgoff.
He really did grow up in Soviet Russia and
although it looks like he now resides in the
UK, he is kind of living the American dream,
or at least some version of it, by starring
in massive American productions like Jack
Ryan and Stranger Things.
To fully understand Alexei, I’m going to
look back at everything he's experienced
over the course of his life, his excitement
over consumerism, and why his death is more
significant than you might think.
As I mentioned, it looks like Alexei is born
in the late 1940s, just judging off of his
appearance.
This would be just shortly after World War
II, and at this time, Joseph Stalin put, what
was referred to by Winston Churchill as the
“iron curtain” in place.
This essentially cut off the Soviet Union
from any contact with non-communist countries,
which included getting any kind of imports,
including food, music, toys, and, yes, even
slurpees.
As Winston Churchhill put it, in his 1946
speech at Westminster College in Missouri,
“From Stettin in the Baltic to Trieste in
the Adriatic, an iron curtain has descended
across the continent.”
This means that Alexei would have grown up
with a very strict life under constant surveillance,
and commodities of more western cultures,
especially the United States, would have been
things that he could only have access to from
the black market.
And if he were caught enjoying these things,
there would be severe consequences.
The theme of the comparison of consumer capitalism
mapped over the falling of the Soviet Union,
is abundant in season three of Stranger Things.
It starts with a commentary by Erica Sinclair,
(of all people) the younger sister of Lucas.
Even though she’s just a kid, she frequently
mentions her love of capitalism.
"Do you know what I love most about this country?
Capitalism"
...and her dislike of communism.
“Just because I don't agree with communism as
an ideology..."
This is also signified later in the season
where Steve Harrington is being brutally interrogated
by Comrade General Stepanov, and tries to
get out of it by offering him a “Scoops
Ahoy” flavor, the “S.S. Butterscotch”
to which Stepanov laughs in Steve’s face.
Or again later, when Hopper and Murray try
to pass as Soviet soldiers, by Murray making
a joke about secretly drinking vodka, while
also identifying that individualism is something
to be shamed.
"Say goodbye to sunlight."
«Попрощайтесь с солнечным светом».
"Who needs sunlight when we have one another, comrade?"
"Кому нужен солнечный свет, когда мы друг с другом, товарищ?"
"Indeed comrade."
"Действительно товарищ".
"And a bottle of Stolichnaya."
«И бутылку Столичной».
*laughs in Russian*
Alexei is first introduced in 1984, as a Russian
scientist, working on a giant drill in an
underground bunker.
When the drill backfires and eviscerates everyone
in it’s proximity, Alexei witnesses the
very “Darth Vader like” murder of his
direct supervisor at the hands of the dead
eye-ed henchman, Grigori, at the request of
Comrade General Stepanov.
As Alexei watches this punishment unfold,
he is informed that we will have
one year to fix the problems and make
the machine work, assuming that if he doesn’t,
he will meet a similar fate to his predecessor.
Alexei is seen again, one year later, in July
of 1985, when Dustin sets up his radio in
an attempt to connect with his summer girlfriend,
only to accidentally intercept a Russian transmission
that he can’t understand.
The transmission is actually a code that’s
coming from the same underground bunker as
earlier, only now Alexei and his team have
made some progress.
“Beautiful isn’t it?”
"Красиво, не правда ли?"
Dustin gets very concerned with intercepting
this message, which is a reflection on the
fear throughout the U.S. of communism, as
mentioned in an earlier episode of Horror
History on the Demogorgon.
In season three, however, the threat of communism
and the Cold War is much more blatant.
Even though he’s a kid, it makes sense that
Dustin would be aware of the danger posed
by the Russians, cause it was evident in the
movies that were released in 1985, when this storyline
takes place.
It can be assumed that Alexei continued to
work on the machine as if his life depended
on it, but he is not seen again until he,
for some reason, is in an underground bunker
of the Hess Family Farm with… this guy.
That’s when Joyce Byers and Jim Hopper break
in, they confront Alexei at gunpoint, where
it is made clear that Alexei does not speak
English:
Alexei: (Russian)
Jim: “I can’t understand you!”
Alexei finds himself in the middle of a scary
combat situation between Hopper and Grigori
-- that scary dead eyed henchmen who killed
his predecessor -- a battle which ends in
Alexei being abducted by Joyce and Hopper.
“You’re coming with us!”
Up until now, Alexei hasn’t had much opportunity
to show any individual personality, and how
could he?
He’s had one job to do, which is to make
a drill work, and his comrade general expects
him to do pretty much only that.
Now that he is captured by Joyce and Hopper,
initially there is still not a ton of room
for his individual personality to show, apart
from him expressing that he may know a better
way to fix Hopper’s car when it breaks down,
only to be ignored, as the car explodes.
That is, until Joyce and Hopper get into an
argument in the woods, stop paying attention
and Alexei is able to make a run for it, and
escape from them.
It seems like Alexei might have a shot at
getting away until he comes to an abrupt stop
on his own, pointing and smiling at something.
As Hopper catches up to him, what he is smiling
at is revealed.
It’s a 7-Eleven.
Alexei wears an expression that looks like
a child who’s about to enter Disneyland.
Alexei, Joyce and Hopper all pound back coca-cola,
which by the way is not a great choice to
hydrate, especially if you’ve been running
through the woods.
Without water.
But it is one of many examples in season three
of Stranger Things where product placement
is heavily showcased.
Similar to the Eggo Waffles from the previous
two seasons, the product placement in season
three is deliberate and holds significant
meaning, especially for Alexei.
As I mentioned earlier, the rise of American
consumerism of the 1980s is all over Stranger
Things season three, with the introduction
of the new Starcourt mall.
The mall is a pretty direct symbol of the
shifting of the American Dream and the end
of the Cold War.
Hawkins’ small town values are being directly
threatened and altered, by showing small businesses
closing, as everyone clambors to the new mall.
Even Hopper’s wardrobe changes.
Stranger Things is known for its nostalgia
for movies of the early 1980s, but the Starcourt
mall allows for a new type of 80s nostalgia.
This is towards the fashion styles, music
and products from this time period.
This even includes a light hearted shopping
montage with Eleven and Max to Madonna’s
"Material Girl", similar to some commercials
of that era.
As always, the show pays a very accurate tribute
to logos and ad campaigns from this time.
Even going so far as to include the big fail
that was “New Coke” by having Lucas try
to compare New Coke to John Carpenter’s
The Thing.
LUCAS: “It’s like Carpenter’s The Thing.
The original… is a classic.
No question about it.
But the remake…
*sips Cola*
Sweeter.
Bolder.
Better.”
MIKE: “You’re insane.”
I wasn’t around for New Coke, but The Thing…
pretty good.
But what does any of this have to do with
Alexei?
It is revealed that the Starcourt Mall is
actually a front for the secret Russian operation
several miles beneath the mall.
Hopper and Joyce commandeer a Cadillac Eldorado
convertible from a very... 1980s... guy.
Then they bring Alexei to the only person
they know who speaks Russian who, naturally, is
Murray Bauman.
Now having a translator, English speaking
audiences such as myself and 99% of you get
to experience Alexei’s personality for the
first time.
We learn that Alexei loves Looney Tunes, Burger
King and is passionate about cherry slurpees.
Roll the clip.
“Tell that stupid man it is not the same
in the slightest.
«Скажи этому глупому человеку, что это не то же самое.
ни в малейшей степени.
And I would like the Cherry I requested.”
И я бы хотел вишню, которую просил ».
“He respectfully disagrees.”
Shortly after this, Alexei is released with
the keys to the convertible.
He is visibly thrilled at the idea of taking
this luxury American vehicle for a joyride.
He gets behind the wheel, floors it and just
when it seems like he’s going to leave his
captors behind, he makes the surprising choice
to stop, turn around and go back to join them.
He even concedes that a strawberry slurpee
tastes the same as cherry.
They make a pitstop Hawkins’s 4th of July
Carnival, and it is here that Alexei reveals
to Murray how badly he wants to enjoy western
commodities, by asking:
Alexei: “And I become an American citizen
and join the fun, yes?”
"И я стал гражданином Америки.
и присоединяйся к веселью, да? "
Murray “Who said you had to be an American
to join the fun?”
«Кто сказал, что ты должен быть американцем?
присоединиться к веселью? "
Murray very directly addresses what the American
Dream would appear to be to Alexei by saying
“It doesn’t get any more American than
this my friend.
«Нет ничего более американского, чем
это мой друг.
Fatty foods, ugly decadency… rigged games…”
Жирная пища, уродливое упадок сил… сфальсифицированные игры… »
Alexei’s whole demeanor is often almost
childlike.
He loves sweets and asks repeatedly if he
can watch Looney Tunes.
Even when he plays darts at the carnival,
he is surrounded by children who cheer for
him, as if he is just another child.
This actually makes a lot of sense when you
consider Alexei’s background and what many
Russian citizens were experiencing during
this time period.
In 1985, the year that Stranger Things season
three takes place, Mikhail Gorbachev
had come to power in Soviet
Russia with the goal to democratize the U.S.S.R.
Where Stalin had put up an Iron Curtain,
Gorbachev promoted new policies of glasnost
and perestroika, or openness
and restructuring.
Ronald Reagan and Gorbachev signed a culture
agreement through Geneva in order to open
communication with the west.
And it’s thanks to this, that we now have
the internet video of Billy Joel having a
mental breakdown on stage.
What does Billy Joel flipping over his piano
while his band continues to rock out
have to do with Alexei?
This Billy Joel performance was part of a
huge tour across the U.S.S.R in 1987.
This tour was a very big deal in opening communication
between the United States and Soviet countries.
While other singers and rock stars had performed
in small venues in the U.S.S.R, Billy Joel
was the first to do a large amphitheatre size
rock show, and naturally, there was a lot
of pressure on him.
As Billy Joel performs, he can be heard yelling
at his camera crew “stop lighting the audience.”
What was happening was there were filmmakers
working on a documentary about the tour.
They wanted to get footage of the Russian
audience enjoying the show but, every time
the lights would come up on the crowd, the
audience would completely freeze.
This was because they, like Alexei, had grown
up under strict communist surveillance, where
enjoying western culture, was illegal and
considered a betrayal.
There may have been new leadership in place,
but openly enjoying something like this was
still kind of taboo.
So Alexei openly enjoying Looney Tunes, Burger
King, slurpees, and carnival games, would
be something he likely wouldn’t be comfortable
doing in front of his Russian superiors.
Especially considering that the guy in charge
wasn’t exactly all about fun and games.
So, when Alexei wins the carnival dart game,
and shows off his giant Woody Woodpecker prize
with a huge smile on his face, it means so
much more to him than what we see on the surface.
Alexei, like many other Russians, missed out
on consumerism as a child and is now making
up for lost time.
Which makes it all the more crushing when
he sees Grigori appear.
When Grigori whispers “traitor” to Alexei
as he passes him after shooting him in the
chest, this isn’t just because Alexei was
helping Hopper, Joyce and Murray in stopping
the Russians from opening the Upside Down,
but also because Alexei’s enjoyment of American
culture was seen as a direct betrayal of his
Soviet regime.
Maybe it’s because of this, that Alexei’s
death, even though he’s just more of a secondary
protagonist, hurts so much.
Or maybe it’s because of his new best friendship
with Murray.
“Murray!
Look!
Смотри!
It’s not rigged!”
Это не подстроено! "
“Ah!”
*Laughs like Woody the Woodpecker*
Either way, watching Alexei die is one of
the many tragic losses that takes place in
Stranger Things season three.
“I..
I just left for a minute for a corn dog.
A stupid corn dog!”
Don’t leave for a corn dog.
Stay here and check out another episode of
Horror History.
Just click that video on the left, and let
me know what other Stranger Things characters
you’d like to see me cover.
Make sure you show your love of American culture
by subscribing to CZsWorld for new horrors
every week, ring that deathbell for all notifications
and I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.